l'appel du président semble avoir été
entendu la vie reprend lentement son
cours
croix des bouquets et son marché s'anime
micheline martel travail pour la
première fois depuis dix jours mais
personne ne vient acheter ses
médicaments le coût des produits de
toutes sortes a augmenté en moyenne de
15% dans les derniers mois
les médicaments sont hors de prix pour
beaucoup d'haïtiens qui gagne moins de
deux dollars par jour
mais il faut vivre manger spaghetti pour
le dîner il coûte 50 % plus cher depuis
le début des manifestations
micheline l'a achetée à crédit
entraide d'un commerçant à un autre mal
obligeant bâtard vient du marché un
aller retour de trois heures qu'elle
fait à pied chaque jour elle n'avait que
cinq cents gourdes aujourd'hui 8 dollars
elle nous montre ce qu'elle rapporte
c'est beaucoup moins qu il y a quelques
semaines car tout coûte cher un film
épique et ça c'est pomme d'été my lovely
rares vendre ses beaux légumes dans son
voisinage c'est la seule façon de gagner
un peu d'argent
son mari ne trouvent pas de travail
commun juillet il arrive ainsi à nourrir
ses cinq enfants
la plupart du temps caché mes vaches à
dubaï voix face à la reconstruction
après le tremblement de terre de 2010 ne
s'est jamais rendu chez elle
le toit de tôle et arraché et les murs
effondrés dans la cour on trouve une
tente de la croix-rouge ou d'or le frère
de my lovely et une moto perché dans un
arbre pour tenir une corde à linge
improvisé see my lovely pouvait garder
pour elle quelques-uns des légumes
qu'elle a rapporté aujourd'hui elle
choisirait les carottes ses préférées
malgré les obstacles elle demeure
dynamique déterminé animés du désir de
vivre
my lovely s'en remet à la grâce de dieu
pour vendre ses légumes et rapportée du
riz à la maison demain il faudra tout
recommencer ici philippe leblanc
radio-canada croix des bouquets